tardigrades are covered in a kind of  skin or shell called a cuticle this  cuticle always stays the same size and  so it must be shed as the tardigrade  grows some species of tardigrades lay  their eggs into this cuticle which  expands to hold them and then when the  cuticle is shed the eggs stay inside  giving them an extra layer of protection  from roving Predators if those eggs  manage to avoid being eaten they will  hatch into tiny little tardigradelets  that oddly enough have the same number  of cells that they will always have but  their cells and thus their bodies will  grow larger tardigrades are marvelously  complex for such tiny animals the most  complex have over 40 000 cells and yes  when they are done extracting nutrients  from their food they have to get rid of  it just like the rest of us